check a perfect score in the final day
of Rapid chess you started off slowly
this event but today you were just a
completely different man what did you do
last night in preparation for this uh
these games
[Music]
of course it's a certain normal for me
is it to lose three games to win three
games you know and I just tried to play
good interesting chess and today I
played interesting chess Fighting Chess
I like it lasts two days but it was a
very bad results
um but today okay maybe uh it was very
interesting games if you were
interesting uh games and I won three
games in Royal no secret it's just it's
my style absolutely let's talk about
this last game because you guys were
blitzing out all the way until I think
move 20 plus
did you guys both of you know this uh
theoretical Battle of course this move
Knight E7 is opening is not
a main move it's uh yeah yeah 97
normally people play Knight F6 but it's
a problem I want to play this move for
myself and some sometimes and for this
reason I analyzed also this Knight G5
line I know 97 looks like is uh just I
mean Knight F6 everyone played by 97
nobody play but not G5 you play all the
line first lines I think and it is the
engine show is like
very close to draw
um but yeah very close but I just played
this move Rook f8 I mean it's surprised
for
um the Mingus yeah I mean look of faith
I think is maybe his first line is like
Rook D5 is draw I mean look D5 but okay
I mean I just play very first look of it
position of course it looks like draw
not draw is less equal position but the
end game is two points it's just let's
speak about the end guess because it
feels like this one as well as the game
against Jeffrey also you had uh quite an
important attempt against Hikaru in that
end game as well you are enjoying these
grindy end games this tournament no I
think the problems no I I I I I I
absolutely I I don't want to play in
games it's uh I'm not very happy with
when I play End games but when okay uh
when okay you just said Hikaru Jeffrey
today I mean I just like to play better
in game if you are better in the game I
like play but if I need a defense I
don't like this one for this reason in
in these three games I just attack in in
game I just play two results
and it was easy to play you know it's I
mean one extra Pawn against the Hikaru
and Jeffrey after the opening of course
everyone want to play this any games
absolutely and uh just to go back
towards the end of this game at this
point after age six he still had the
draw with this move King to ga yeah of
course I I think yeah yeah but for this
I I calculate this but what what I can
do I mean I I heard some maybe another
idea but I think King G8 I can play G7
it's same idea but okay yeah and then
not no improve okay I don't know why I
played very fast these moves but this
looks winning position because two pawns
is very strong but I I just calculated
it's like winning position somewhere but
yeah it's my mistake yes maybe it's not
winning because how to improve my chance
yeah now that easy rock to chc4 is
coming yeah Shaq 18 games at Google
what's your routine been like this
tournament what do you do after you
finish games okay I mean first of all
not easy tournament every day is very
good very interesting chess and of
course relaxing and just
uh to try to some relax I don't know uh
you know okay you can
every day every game and for this reason
I just injured from chess it will lose
our win is okay I just play next game
and okay I mean it's very strong
tournament what I can say and just
relaxing and preachers take it one game
at a time enjoy the games that seems
like solid advice thank you very much
Jack we'll see you tomorrow